voilà déjà merci à vous philo mais une
bonne journée à vous merci à vous on
passe maintenant à la revue de presse
au vu de pressignac celle mais bonjour
accès bonjour on commence par football
le monde du football a les yeux rivés
sur le qatar est une étape clé sur la
route de la prochaine coupe du monde
écrit golf times la cérémonie du tirage
au sort se déroule aujourd'hui on essaie
d'oublier évidemment les nombreuses
polémiques autour de ce mondial depuis
qu'il était attribué au qatar pour se
concentrer sur sur le sport et le who's
who du monde du football va converger au
dos à eghezée bichonne comme une shon
center renchérit le golf times un
quotidien anglophone du qatar l'équipe
le journal le détail pour sa part les
chapeau du tirage au sort quatre
chapeaux il y aura 8 poules la
compétition c'est en fin d'année et
notamment dans le chapeau 1 la france
c'est là où il ya les principales les
principaux concurrents les skis ceux qui
sont les mieux classés plus le qatar en
tant que pays d'accueil attention vous
aurez vu vous aurez remarqué dans le
chapeau 2 il ya quand même un sacré
morceau l'allemagne qui se trouvent dans
ce chapeau 2 et puis l'équipe toujours
s'est amusé à imaginer le tirage au sort
le plus difficile pour la france ça
serait l'allemagne le sénégal et
l'équateur et le tirage au sort le plus
abordable sur le papier états unis
tunisie et arabie saoudite ipi pour tout
comprendre tout savoir sur ce tirage au
sort je vous invite à vous rendre sur le
site de france 24
je rappelle aussi d'ailleurs à ce propos
les qualifiés pour l'afrique le sénégal
champion d'afrique le cameroun le ghana
le maroc et la tunisie voilà tout ce
qu'il faut savoir avant le tirage au
sort ce soir heure de paris des groupes
au qatar c'est à retrouver sur france 24
points comme l'adresse exacte autre
sujet c'est bien entendu la guerre en
ukraine axel mais le conflit est l'une
de ses conséquences gazière qu'oman se
passer du gaz russe regardez la une du
journal espagnol abc
l'allemagne on comprend avec ce titre et
a quasiment pas de traduire sénéga
accepte harel chantal à des poutines
l'allemagne refuse d'accepter le
chantage de tine alors qu'il ne lui
reste que 80 jours de gaz l'allemagne
continue à baisser continuera de payer
le gaz russe en euros malgré les
dernières déclarations du président
russe un déclarations dans lesquelles il
a menacé de couper l'approvisionnement
des pays inamicaux qui refusent de payer
en roubles le mécanisme entre en vigueur
aujourd'hui et le dos de choses et il
s'interroge comment payer le gaz russe
car poutine veut continuer oui c'est
compliqué quand même a accepté d euros
pour les livraisons de gaz à l'union
européenne et même l'ancien banquier
central mario draghi ne sait pas
exactement comment cela va fonctionner
la guerre en ukraine qui reste l'un des
principaux sujets de l'élection
présidentielle en france oui oui alors
d'abord poutine poutine qui reste isolée
dans sa tour d'ivoire et c'est le temps
qui en parle le président russe se
serait-il trompé par son entourage qu'il
dissimulerait certaines mauvaises
nouvelles je vous invite à aller lire le
temps sur cette question mais
effectivement ensuite il y à cette
question plus générale cette guerre en
ukraine qui s'invite dans la
présidentielle française et c'est à lire
dans dans le figaro qui souligne que
c'est la première fois depuis plus de 50
ans que la menace d'une guerre mondiale
plane sur cette élection dont l'élément
que le mot du sous titre et ce alors
qu'il ya une tendance de fond qui
s'impose depuis environ trente cinq ans
et bien cette tendance de fond noté par
la fondation pour l'innovation politique
c'est que toutes les présidentielles on
veut augmenter le poids des candidat
antisystème et cette hausse continue de
la protestation électorale est devenue
la norme voilà une analyse à lire à
travers aussi un sondage dans le figaro
et puis libération la campagne du
président sortant est percuté par le
rapport sénatorial qui lève le voile sur
le recours massif de l'état à de coûteux
cabinet de conseil depuis le début du
quinquennat notamment l'emblématique cas
du géant américain mckinsey accusé en
plus de contourner l'impôt en france ce
n'est plus le quoi qu'il en coûte
qu'avait a lancé manuel macro début de
la crise sanitaire mais le couac qu'il
en coûte et puis si vous ne savez pas
pour qui voter je vous invite à faire ce
quiz assez amusant quel candidat de quel
candidat êtes vous le plus proche un
quizz sur le site du monde.fr et
je les fais j'avoue et c'est parfois
assez surprenant le résultat de ce quiz
de mesure votre enthousiasme excellent
met vraiment à fin du pouvoir d'achat
peut-être qui fait partie des thèmes
récurrents des campagnes électorales oui
le plein à tout prix ça c'est la une
aujourd'hui de paris nice parce que de
paris-nice de nice matin parce que parce
qu'à partir d'aujourd'hui pour faire
baisser un peu les prix des carburants à
la pompe qui ont dépassé de 2 euros par
litre en raison de la hausse des cours
du brut je n'aimerais pas la guerre en
ukraine le gouvernement a promis de
prendre en charge une partie de ce
surcoût à partir d'aujourd'hui donc une
remise de 18 centimes d'euros par litre
de carburant est en vigueur dans les
stations service et quand on ouvre les
pages de nice matin il y à ce petit
dessin qui m'a amusé et que je vous
propose on voit un automobiliste qui dit
à force de tourner pour trouver le
carburant le moins cher on est à court
d'essence et sa femme répond j'espère
que c'est un poisson d'avril et oui on
est aujourd'hui le 1er avril et je te
dirai un petit peu de sucre dans la
presse assez peu de
sujets liés au poisson d'avril je
voulais vous ans découpé un repas vous
mettre sur le dos je n'ai pas trouvé
leur n'est pas trop à la broderie merci
quand même excellent mais c'était la
revue de presse on marque une très
courte pause dans